want to be happy build a life not just a
business hey it's devon carmichael and
this channel was created to help you
overcome the number one challenge that
is holding you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know there's
something more inside you too
you've got michael jordan level talent
at something so get ready to be
inspired motivated and shifted by sad
guru and some of his best wisdom
enjoy
can you see me right now all of you can
you see me
just point out where i am use your hands
and point out
can you see me oh you got it wrong
you know i'm a mystic
you're getting it completely wrong now
this light is falling upon me reflecting
going through your lenses inverted image
in your retina you know the whole story
right
where do you see me right now within
yourself
where do you hear me right now within
yourself
where have you seen the whole world
within yourself
have you ever experienced anything
outside of yourself
everything that ever happened to you
darkness and light happen within you
pain and pleasure happen within you joy
and misery happen within you
have you ever experienced anything
outside of yourself
no so what i am asking you is
what happens within you who should
determine how it should happen
what happens within you who should
determine how
this should happen somebody else
definitely you should determine what
should happen within this isn't it
so if you determine what's happening
within this your whole experience
of life will be determined by you
nobody else but you isn't it the events
around you
may not be determined by you but how
your experience of life is on this
planet is
100 determined by you if you take charge
of this
if you leave it loose just about anybody
will determine it
they will not consciously they also like
you
by accident see grace is available to
everybody
it's like sunlight sunlight is available
to everybody
but only those who open their eyes will
see
that's the way it is but is it not there
is
it there only for me not for you there's
no such thing it's available for
everybody
it's just that are you receptive
when we talk about receptivity
see the entire process of yoga the word
yoga itself means this
the word yoga means union union means
what
right now in most people's experience
it is me versus universe
this is how people are experiencing life
otherwise why continuous anxiety
fear they think they are fighting for
their life all the time why
they are fighting the whole universe
individual and the universal
being in competition with the universe
is a stupid thing to do
not a single day passes for me right
without witnessing tears of joy and love
around me
every day somebody will be shedding
tears of love and joy
i don't think there's a better way to
live in this world
and all of us should strive to create
our own circles
of joyfulness and pleasantness around us
because if you are not joyful by your
own nature
if you are always going around with the
fear of suffering
as long as fear of suffering is there
within you
you will never walk your life with full
stride it will always be half a step
most human beings have crippled
themselves simply because of fear of
suffering what will happen to me is
always the question
whatever happens this is how i will be
if this assurance comes to you
only now you will want to scale the
peaks of life and see
what about it if it happens
makes no difference to you if it doesn't
happen makes no difference to you
that's when you would like to really
explore every dimension of life
so first and foremost thing is this that
your way of being is not determined by
what's around you
if you bring this one aspect to you
there is no fear of suffering
once there is no fear of suffering you
will traverse the breadth and length of
this
life without hesitation there are no
right things to do
in life if you choose something
and put everything that you have into it
it'll become a great thing
is it the right thing is it the best
thing when you say is it the right thing
what you're asking is it the best thing
to do in life
there is no best thing to do in life
anything that you take up and if you put
your heart and soul into it
it becomes a great thing is it the best
thing
no then what is the best thing
there is no such thing don't look at
yourself
as a a deliate or an idiot
whatever you want to call yourself
if you're just a piece of life
hello and today you're here one day
you'll be poop
gone you're a brief life
i want you to just imagine you've seen
those insects which come when it rains
you know
ants which fly suppose you are that
you just came alive
gone that's what you are
just compared to the span of your life
the insect's life is looking so
meaningless and
gone that's what the rivers are thinking
about you
poo poo poop and gone yes or no
compared to their lifespan you are just
like that insect or less than the insect
isn't it so
i am not somebody who ever debated is
this the right thing to do in my life
what was needed i jumped into it
because if you're a constipated life
you will always be thinking
about what to do what not to do what to
do what not to do what is my passion
what is not my passion
why the hell are you not passionate
about everything
hello why are you not passionate about
everything in the existence
you're only passionate about one thing
means what
you constipate it that's what it means
idiots do things that they don't like to
do suffer for their whole life
because they think it's needed or they
think it's their duty
intelligent people do
what they love to do they enjoy their
life to some extent
but a genius learns to do what is needed
joyfully
that's when your genius flowers
because it's no more about you now
there's a limitless
way of looking at life to create fear
you have to use excessive imagination
to not be in fear you don't have to do
anything
where is happening because of excessive
imagination things that have not
happened
you're creating
what may happen in your mind
happens in thousand different formats
and most probably it never happens
the things that you feared take hundred
things that you have feared
probably 99 of them never happened isn't
it
yes so you're here your fear is
always about that which does not exist
you cannot fight or you cannot overcome
that which does not exist
we can overcome something with that
exists
you cannot overcome that which does not
exist
you just have to give up that effort
enjoy the fear after all it's your
making you like horror movies
yes i mean you're saying no but you
you're producing them it's just they're
not making money that's all
fear means you're producing horror
movies in your mind nobody else is
willing to watch
that's bad for the producer
but you're producing them
so you produce something else
produce a comedy a love story
suspense thriller
try and see today just sit down
produce a love story a suspense thriller
a comedy five five minutes movies you
make
in your mind really start using your
mind differently
it's just gotten into your pattern just
gotten your pattern of just creating
horror movies all the time
you have watched enough horror movies
they're boring
[Music]
create something else even it's not that
if you produce these movies those things
will happen in your life
still they may not happen at least you
enjoy the movie
in reality it may not happen so what
at least you enjoy what's happening in
your mind
if you cannot enjoy what's happening in
the world isn't it
that much privilege every human being
deserves isn't it so
even if the world is not kind to him at
least his own mind should be kind to him
should produce some nice movies
i must say this just a couple of weeks
ago
i was in conversation with someone who
is considered
some kind of an expert on internet
affairs and social media and all this
so he's been looking at our material
in the youtube and various other
platforms
and i said easily i can give you 50
times more than what is there
you know just people work on all the
thousands of hours of audio and video
that's there in the archive
50 times more in a year's time we can
multiply it by 50.
that much material is there he said said
guru already what is there here you're
throwing it all over the place it's
worth a billion dollars
i said see what will i do with the
billion dollars my interest is seven
billion people
i have no interest in billion dollars
what do i do with it
my interest is people around us so many
people will do so many things that we
don't like
yes or no so many things in mumbai
happening
things that we don't like are everyday
happening
but at least within you only what you
want should happen within this
isn't it
i cannot decide that only what i want
should happen with you
but i can definitely decide only what i
want must happen within me
isn't it if you could decide
only what you want should happen within
you
would you choose anger or joy
what's your choice please choose i'm
going to bless you
see you want the highest level of
pleasantness for yourself isn't it
then why is such a thing not happening
as i said earlier
you never at the user's manual
how this functions has not been looked
at do not go by the example of people
who came here a few
few years earlier than you that
no no my mother also was like that my
grandmother also was getting angry so i
am also getting angry
they should not be the leading lights of
your life
i want you to look at it your thought
your emotion your body must happen the
way you want isn't it
if somebody else can decide what should
happen within you
this is ultimate slavery isn't it so
what happens around you maybe we can
decide
but nobody should decide except yourself
what happens within you
if you decide you would keep this in the
high state of pleasantness for sure
you wouldn't be battling with anger it's
not just about
anger fear stress tension don't address
them separately
essentially your mind is not taking
instructions from you
why because you don't know where the
damn keyboard is
yet we gave you a super computer
you do not know where where the keyboard
is so one day you did this something
worked
another day you did this something work
you know have you seen people
the radio doesn't work boom and it works
sometimes
that's not a technology that's chance
have you seen this if something doesn't
work people think tupped up
tough it'll work and a lot of people are
using this for human beings also
what people are generally calling
as destiny
is essentially what they end up creating
unconsciously when i say unconsciously
as you sit here right now as everybody
sits here right now
there is physical activity going on
within the system
there is mental process there is
emotional activity
and of course the life energies are
active
every moment they're taking in hundreds
of inputs whether you're conscious or
not conscious
so if i ask you a question since this
morning
from the time you woke up till now of
these four dimensions of activity
how much have you conducted consciously
what percentage do you think few things
how much percentage do you think
25 percent you are very generous man
it's well below one percent
if you walk from there to there there
will be 25
different kind of smells that you're not
conscious of that the body registers
and records there are
100 different kinds of sounds the body
registers
that you are not conscious of like this
throughout the day
and night in wakefulness and sleep this
is happening
when you are only conscious of less than
one percent of your activity
definitely life will look like an
accident
hello when
99 of the things that you're doing
you're doing unconsciously
definitely life look will look
accidental
if the accident see it just so happened
somebody fell off on the street and had
a brain injury
after that suddenly they started working
their mathematics
in a wonderful way but that was only one
a thousand other people who cracked
their skull
never recovered from that or they died
or those who lived on
lived on much diminished
so being accidentally
fortunate is not the way to exist
so whenever a pleasant accident happens
we say it's destiny
some of you even say god
doing things to me when did you make a
partnership with him i don't know
so
shall i tell you a story okay
this happened sherlock holmes you know
sherlock holmes
and watson went out camping
and early morning
3 30 am sherlock holmes
nudged watson he opened his eyes what
what do you see he asked
well i see a clear sky and stars
what does it mean to you
he said well that means tomorrow is
going to be a wonderful sunny day
then he asks what does it mean to you
is that it means someone has stolen our
tent
[Laughter]
so we don't know
what went missing and something may fall
here and there by chance
but that's not the way life works
if a human being doesn't take it upon
himself
or herself to make their own destiny
they are still having an evolutionary
problem
that is they are still
not yet fully there because being human
means this that we can conduct our life
consciously
being human means this that we can craft
our life
the way we want
but this destiny business is a good
insurance to handle your failure
whenever you fail destiny
it's god's will you did this activity
where to get us awake and energized you
had us close our eyes and you counted
the three
and then we had to yell lose our
inhibitions and
and let it all out and that idea of kind
of losing control and losing inhibitions
for me personally has actually been uh a
challenge
and i was hoping to get your perspective
uh i have
never done drugs because i don't want to
lose control i fight roller coasters
because i don't like losing control of
the body
i i i i'm i'm excited for your
perspective i don't know why it uh
it came up because last night i did my
best but it's always been um
a challenge or a struggle for me and i'm
i'm just curious to get your perspective
nature has imposed
substantial amount of
restrictions on life
you can just zoom out into the space
there is enough restrictions you don't
have to invent your own restrictions on
top of it
so if you invent your own restrictions
slowly over a period of time you become
a constipated life
that means life won't happen easy
it happens in small happenings
so being in a state of abandon not out
of control
being in a state of abandoned means
all the stops that you have put on
yourself you pulled it off
nature stops are still there therefore
your safety
and your well-being but why are you
imposing stops
there's enough gravity is holding you
down that's
bad enough now you want to hold yourself
down
why because fear what is the fear about
the fear is always about if i do this i
may suffer
so that is a fundamental of my work to
bring you to your place where there's no
fear of suffering
so you must understand this if
everything that you try to do
is becoming frictious friction
is happening obviously you are the
sandpaper
you know what's a sandpaper
i'll ask them to provide you a sandpaper
a small piece
every day whenever you have a friction
with somebody just
scrape your skin somewhere
so if you don't cure yourself quickly
you won't have any skin left
[Music]
when you don't have any skin left then
you will not touch anything
you will not create you will not look
for any friction
you will walk in suppose you had no skin
how would you walk
even a little feather won't touch you
like that you will walk isn't it because
everything hurts now
so if you want that kind of treatment we
can do
otherwise first come to your senses
friction is happening means
wherever you go friction is happening
obviously
one simple thing you can do to reduce
friction is i've told you many times but
you've not done this is
whatever you're saying in a day
or in an hour or in a minute
how many words per minute are you
uttering
bring it down to 50 percent still do the
same work
you will see a whole lot of friction
will go down simply because you're not
blabbering
yes and
we've been trying to train you whatever
you see
whether you see a man woman child cow
donkey donkey also
no
how will friction not happen it will
happen
so only when satguru is here like this
rest of the time like this it won't work
bring this into you not just as a
symbolism
genuinely
so friction
the two kinds one within ourselves
outside is just an expression and a
consequence
so this whole thing about inner
engineering means just this
that when you sit here you can sit here
without any friction
if you can sit here without any friction
outside friction also will go down
but when you meet a sandpaper there must
be some friction
there are sandpapers hello
so when you meet a science paper there
must be friction
otherwise how there will be so generally
we avoid
sand paper if we can but sometimes we
have to work with them
when we have to work with the sandpaper
you need tact
this is something you have to learn this
will not come
this is not nothing spiritual about it
this is
tact in the society sometimes it doesn't
work
but it's a question of skill some people
who are not spiritual in any way
they are very tactful when they meet
sandpapers
you will see this kind of agents and
others who are working in government
offices and
in political atmospheres they are so
smooth
it doesn't matter how rough the other
person is these people
just they'll just get their job done
and leave
so working with sandpaper
takes a little bit of skill and
experience
nothing spiritual about it it's a social
skill
but uh generally
in the ashram very few sand papers once
in a way
people pop up sand on them but they drop
it you know
they don't keep it all the time
sometimes
sometimes they're like that they're not
like that all the time
so when they are like that when the
porcupine has its
thing up you must keep away a bit
when it's down you can talk to it
it doesn't keep it up all the time it
doesn't have the strength to do that
so your friction you must understand
it's just
you when it comes to what you want to do
you must think clearly it's very
important thinking clearly means
the question is not about what will get
me this what will get me that
are you is your life precious to you all
of you i'm asking
your life is it precious to you so
before you
invest this life into something
you must look whether today if i invest
my life into this
after 25 years will it still mean a lot
to me
after 50 years will it still mean a lot
to me at the end of my life you turn
back and i
look will i be proud of this or will i
be ashamed of what i'm doing right now
it doesn't matter what other people say
but you should not do anything that you
will feel ashamed of
isn't it so it doesn't matter people say
so many things
everybody has opinion it's their
business but
you don't do something that you will
feel ashamed of isn't it
then you're turning against yourself
somebody turns against you you can leave
them and go somewhere else
if you turn against yourself you'll have
to live with it forever
so this is all you have to look at it
somebody something will get you money
something will get you comfort that's
not the point
what you choose to do will it give you a
life
when i say give it give your life are
you just
trying to make a living or are you
trying to make a life out of this
it's important making a living
is not an issue a worm an insect
a bird an animal all of them are making
their life
making a living isn't it so they're even
making a life out of it but
definitely they're making a living so
making a living with such a big brain
is not an issue earning your food is not
an
issue making a living is not an issue
only problem is you want to live like
somebody else that's an endless problem
i want to live is not a problem i want
to live like you
this is a problem so
it is important if you consider your
life as a precious life
you must make sure you make a wonderful
life out of this
if you go outside in the garden and try
to catch an
ant the bhu ant
who is born here has grown up here and
probably he'll die here
that bhu ant if you try to catch him
he'll say okay to hell with my life okay
crush me if you want
is it so he'll do everything to protect
himself
he values his life isn't it
very much or no tiny little creature
that we may not even notice we may step
on him without even seeing him
unfortunately but
he values his life immensely
does he know he's got spark
but you a human being
at least on this planet you're the peak
of evolution
physiologically at least yes
if other behavioral aspects if you may
have questions
but physiologically at least the most
evolved creature on the
planet what the most evolved creature on
the planet means is
it has the most complex neurological
system
and it has the highest level of cerebral
capability
that means you can think you can
remember
you have memory you have a very vivid
sense of memory
and a fantastic sense of imagination
an ant doesn't have such a vivid sense
of memory
nor does he have any great imagination
yes some
but he has a presence of mind about the
life that he is living
because the education systems that you
are going through right from
kindergarten level
is such that it is about everything
except you
it's about everything else somebody is
phd in tourism
somebody's phd in biotechnology
somebody's phd in something
nothing about this how does this
function
there is no attention at all a human
being
functions you know you have a kala
bhairava temple
here what this means is
a human being exists in three times
he lives because of the richness of his
memory
how rich is your memory determines what
you will do and what you will not do
right now isn't it so
so memory is important the present
experience
is important and how vivid is your
imagination for tomorrow
is very important right now the problem
is
these things have all gotten mixed up
because discipline of faculty has simply
not come
nothing has been taught to our children
that there needs to be
discipline means people think english
kind of discipline walking like this
like idiots
discipline of faculty is not there
because of this your own mind turns
against you
what happened 10 years ago you still
suffer
hello what may happen day after tomorrow
you already suffer
because there's no discipline of faculty
you don't know how to use your memory
you don't know how to use your
imagination your memory makes you suffer
your imagine makes
imagination makes you suffer and you
think you're suffering your life
you are not suffering your life you're
only suffering the two
greatest faculties of being human vivid
sense of memory and a fantastic sense of
humor
imagination isn't it so if you suffer
the greatest faculties that you have
what can we do with you
if you suffer a ailment understandable
if you suffer a disability
understandable if you suffer your
ability
hopeless case yes or no
you're suffering your capabilities if
you're suffering your disability
it's all right you're suffering your
capabilities
i must tell you this about four or five
months ago i think
you might have seen it on the news a
young lady 34 year old lady
who was a television anchor in hyderabad
jumped off the fifth floor window
killed herself left a note
nobody is responsible for my death my
brain
is my enemy
how many million years it took to get
this brain to this size
and now it becomes your enemy she
articulated this
but this is true with almost 90 percent
of the human beings
they are suffering their own
intelligence isn't it
if you take away half their brain
if you take away half their brain they
will be peaceful
yes and that is why a whole
bunch of idiots are going about saying
that the ultimate goal of life is peace
of mind
such people will only rest in peace we
are completely committed to one
dimension of our intelligence which we
call as the intellect
which is just the thought process
thought can only happen
with the data that you have gathered
through five senses
which is very limited one thing another
thing is
the nature of data that the sensors
gather are only useful for survival
process
the very nature of how you see things
how you hear smell and taste and touch
life is only relevant for survival
process
if you wanting to know the life itself
then these instruments of perception are
no good
even what is light and darkness is a
debate between you
and another creature which sees darkness
as light isn't it
if you sit with an owl and start an
argument
as to which is light and which is
darkness
it's an endless argument but who do you
think is right
hello if you're saying
both you're either in the diplomatic
core
or or you have a successful marriage
[Applause]
[Music]
you will learn to say both both but
which is the truth
what i see is the truth or what the owl
says the truth
that's not the point it is just that
nature has opened up our sense
perception
as it is necessary for our survival
accordingly it has opened up sense
perceptions for different creatures as
it is necessary for their survival
but if survival is all you're seeking
this is good enough
the five senses but once you have come
as a human being
somehow survival is not good enough
if your stomach is empty there's only
one issue about food
but once the stomach becomes full you
have a hundred issues
going on so the nature of the human
being is such
no matter what you do you want to be
something more
than what you are right now and if that
something more
happens something more something old
it's an endless pursuit
so somewhere a human being is seeking
a limitless expansion but
trying to do it with physical means
the very nature of physicality is a
defined boundary
if there is no defined boundary there is
no possibility of physical happening in
the universe
but now a human being is longing for the
boundless
the two in installments
and through physical means through the
boundary you're trying to become
boundless
the desire is fantastic the method is
hopeless
because the moment you identify yourself
with something
your intellect's work is just to protect
that identity
if you whatever the identities of nation
or family or gender or race religion
whatever the moment you
identify yourself with something your
intellect will
only function around that to protect
that so
it is a certain type of prejudice the
moment you're identified
so the only thing i did with my life is
i never
identified myself with anything and life
just
exploded within me in ways that thought
seems so puny
that i do not indulge in thought most of
the time the japanese people
eat much less fat
than the americans and the british
because of this people believe
they have much less incidents of
cardiac arrest less people in japan die
of heart failures and heart attacks
than they do in uk and in united states
but the french eat a lot more fat
but still they have much less incidence
of cardiac problems
compared to the british and the
americans
the japanese people don't drink much
wine
so they have much less cardiac problems
but the italians drink only wine
and they also have much less cardiac
problems than the english and the
americans
so the deduction is it is the english
language which is the problem
[Applause]
the english speaking which is the
problem
so this has been a problem everywhere
that
we try to transplant what is happening
in one place
simply as it is in another place
not just geographically and culturally
even from individual to individual
that what worked for one person
we try to make it work for another
person and destroy that person
completely
unfortunately this is labeled as
education
mass producing people
though we are a mass of people on this
planet a huge number
over seven billion people still you were
produced individually not mass produced
are you
right from my childhood i've been
noticing this
that most adults want to
teach something when they see children
all those damn things which have not
worked in their life
this is one wow you have to take with me
that is
from this moment onwards in your life
you will not
pass on anything that has not worked for
you to anybody else
hello
even if you cannot pass on the best
things to other people
at least what is not worked for you you
don't give it to anybody
will you do this
does anger work for you so don't give it
to anybody
does misery work for you does depression
work for you
so if you are angry if you're depressed
you're miserable
just shut up okay
and sit in one place and handle it being
playful
always has been understood as
irresponsibility
yes do you know right from your
childhood
and probably to your children also
you're doing this if they're just
playful you think it's irresponsible
the most responsible way to live is that
you're playful with life
it's absolutely irresponsible to carry a
long face and walk around in this planet
yes or no isn't it
absolutely irresponsible to walk around
with misery
yes that's the most irresponsible thing
you can do
so being playful is not irresponsibility
being playful is being very responsible
and responsive to life only when you're
playful you can do that
when you're serious the world doesn't
exist for you you want your nonsense
yes when you're serious it's just about
you and your nonsense
the world and other life does not exist
for you only when you are playful
you can pay attention to everything you
can truly respond to everything in the
world
only if you are playful otherwise you
cannot
just the burden of it will kill you
people are always thinking
that something else or somebody else is
restricting their freedom
but once freedom is lost simply because
they are tangled up with their own body
and their own mind these are two
dimensions of you
two faculties unless
your body and your mind is fully in your
hands
if they're continuously working for you
never against you
only then you can live a successful life
people have approached inner well-being
either with belief systems
or philosophies or ideologies or some
wacky
ideas of their own
it's time to approach your inner
well-being in a scientific manner
as there is science and technology to
create external well-being
there is a whole science and technology
to create inner well-being
that is what we call as calling as inner
engineering technologies for well-being
it is time that you approach your inner
well-being also
in a scientific systematic way
and employ technologies to create this
well-being
everything else you're using technology
you understand
that technology can facilitate
everything on the outside
why don't you understand that the best
piece of technology on this planet is
this human mechanism
unless you approach it properly it will
not heal
living here as half a human being is not
good enough
right now people's idea of success is
they're doing better than their neighbor
now your idea of success should be
that you are a full-fledged life because
this is not my idea
this is not my philosophy this is the
longing of every life
every worm insect bird tree animal and
also human being
are always striving to become a
full-fledged
life but we know what is a full-fledged
worm
we know what is a full-fledged insect we
know what is a full-fledged apple tree
but we don't know what's a full-fledged
human being that's where the problem is
how to address the larger issues of my
life
there are no large issues in your life
somebody needs to help me understand
that
what is the large issue that you're
talking about it is just about what job
to take
which girl to marry
where to go for vacation
whether whether to get married or not
get married you know
these are things isn't it these are not
large issues these are
little things in your life
yes oh is it just a small thing whom i
get married to
i'm not saying it's a small thing but as
an issue it's a small issue
little issue as a consequence to your
life yes it has many things
but this is something that human beings
have done for
millions of years we have enough
experience on these things isn't it
we know that whatever job we take
whoever we marry
it is just the way we make out of it
every experience of life you can make it
an enriching experience
every experience in your life you can
make a curse out of it
see there is nothing wrong
in your job whatever job you're doing
there's nothing wrong getting this job
there's nothing along
wrong in losing this job there's nothing
wrong in getting married there's nothing
wrong in getting divorced
there's nothing wrong in not getting
married
there is nothing wrong in anything there
is nothing wrong in this or that
but it is just that you make misery out
of it
that's wrong
if you do this you make misery out of it
if you do that you make misery out of it
that's what is wrong with you
so you got married is it wrong that's
not the point
there's nothing wrong with it you did
not get married is it wrong
no there's nothing wrong with it that's
wonderful too you got divorced is it
wrong
no that's also wonderful it is just that
you make
misery out of everything that's what is
wrong
you just address that one issue
everything will be settled
right now what are the instruments of
your experience
you know you're here only because you
can see
hear smell taste and touch this is the
only way you know that you're here right
now
suppose your toes off don't okay suppose
you doze off
you don't know that you're here isn't it
yes
even though you're here your heart is
beating everything is functioning the
world is on we are all here
but you won't know that you're here nor
will you know that i am here or anybody
else is here
isn't it yes all that's happened is life
is on full-on even within you
only thing is these five sensory organs
have shut down
so your entire experience of life right
now is happening because you can see
here
smell taste and touch just look at the
nature of the sensory organs in the very
nature
they're outward bound isn't it
can you roll your eyeballs inward and
scan yourself
no
shall i give you a bad example sorry
your our nose is located nigh right
above our mouth
suppose you don't brush your teeth for
three days
[Music]
though this nose is right here it won't
tell you you have not brushed your teeth
the whole room will know you have not
brushed your teeth but you will not know
this is the human predicament
it's very easy to see what's wrong with
this guy what's wrong with her what's
wrong with her
it's very it takes a lot of observation
to see what's wrong with this
that level of keenness of observation is
missing in most people
they need to cultivate that if your
friend
is doesn't not do well you'll feel sad
about it
if he does very well you'll feel very
sad about it
so you have fixed yourself in such a way
whichever way you cannot be happy
[Music]
you you're in a self-defeating mode no
matter what happens
you will not be happy if you want to
understand what i'm saying
you go and stand out on one of the main
streets in bangalore city
leave the poor people who are selling
karlakai on the street side
leave them people who are driving there
only look at those bmws mercedes and
materialities and whatever is going
around in bangalore city
only look at the dream cars okay because
many of you
may have dreams also of this
just look at all these people you think
they're in a profusion of joy
driving this car like that no only
in case it's a stolen car you'll see the
joy
[Applause]
otherwise no
so success has not brought joy to them
if they're failed of course they're
frustrated
because the very mode of approach is
like this
if this mode of approach comes whichever
way it's not going to work
because it's not even about you it's
always about somebody here
it's never about you the simple thing is
this
see if your joy
your sadness your happiness your misery
is determined by something or somebody
around you
the chances of you being joyful in your
life is remote
yes or no is it true
that human experience is created from
within
hello hello i'm asking all of you
is it true that human experience joy or
misery agony or ecstasy
madness or sanity everything is created
from inside
at least if you're a manager if you're
going to be a manager
at least what is happening from within
you must happen your way
because essentially management means
having situations the way we want it
yes management is what
having situations the way we want it
well if the world is not happening your
way at least this one must be happening
your way otherwise what kind of
management is this
here there's only one person huh
here there are a thousand people they
may not listen to you they got their own
stuff
but here there's only one person at
least here
what you want must happen isn't it if
what you want happened
would you keep yourself blissed out or
miserable
what's your choice you must choose i'm
going to bless you now
if you had a choice would you be rather
be blissed out
or miserable no
bless that of course so if such a thing
is not happening
then all these problems come if things
work it is a problem if they don't work
it's a problem
if you get a seat in this institution
it's a problem
if you cannot get out of this it's a
problem
[Music]
you like this place so much you don't
mind staying here it's not like that
you must get in and you must get get out
ahead of others
everything it's never about you it's
always about something else
outside is a variable situation
who these people are today tomorrow we
don't know what they will say
yes tomorrow morning we don't know what
they will say
if your way of being is determined by
all these people
then you are a mess you're bound to be a
mess see you are a product of this
planet yes or no
whatever nonsense individuals may think
about themselves
we are all just a pop-up from this
planet you've seen those pop-ups on the
computer screen
pop-pop yes
you're just a pop-up you'll be gone
you can't believe you will be gone huh
me i will be gone
yes all the very smart people countless
number of people who walked this planet
before and you and me where the hell are
they huh
not a sign all became topsoil isn't it
so
weren't they pop-ups aren't
you may think you have a great life and
this and that
as far as the earth is concerned it's
just recycling its soil
just throws you up and draws you back
throws you up and draws you back
so in this little pop-up the important
thing and the most important thing is
you create sensitivity within you such
sensitivity
that every dimension of life comes into
your experience
before you fall dead is it not important
you experience this life in this fullest
possible
scale yes or no experience means people
think
we must party every day no no same damn
thing how many times you will do
there is much more for the human life to
explore
you must become sensitive when i say
sensitive
because the word sensitive is used in
the wrong way in the sense
when people say oh she's very sensitive
we are supposed to understand
she will get hurt for just about
anything
yes no being sensitive to life and being
ego sensitive are two different things
being sensitive to life means if you
walk into this hall
you experience everything that's here
you don't miss a thing
if you walk outside you don't miss a
thing every dimension of life should
come into your experience
see as we sit here this is my body that
is your body
do what you want these two things will
not become one
this is my mind that is your mind do
what you want these things
will not become one they may overlap on
some issues
and we may feel that we are one with
each other but
my mind is my mind your mind is your
mind isn't it
but there is no such thing as my life
and your life
this is a living cosmos you captured a
little bit
i captured a little bit that's about it
but now we think this is my life and
that is your life there is no such thing
this is a living cosmos you've blown a
small bubble
somebody might have blown a little
bigger bubble
did you blow soap bubbles when you were
young oh yeah you still do
yes so when you blow soap bubbles
somebody had this big bubble somebody
else had that big bubble
oh went on saying this is my bubble this
your bubble but poop it went
once it goes poop you did not say this
is my hair and this is your air
similarly there is no such thing as my
life and your life
there is just a living cosmos if you
capture
more life then you will see
you have more grace the depth dimension
and scope of your life
is determined by how much life you
capture within you
it doesn't matter what kind of body you
have what kind of intelligence you have
if you have not captured substantial
life within you you will live a small
life
that's how it is how do you do this
there are systematic ways of approaching
this
or simply by involvement and exuberance
by commitment people may capture a
larger life
by absolutely being committed to
something focused on something
somebody may capture a certain amount of
life which is more
than what is considered normal you
talked one time i thought this was so
interesting about
how every time you get a belief it's
like a conclusion and every conclusion
is a death unto itself and it's like
shutting a door on something yes
otherwise see you just see
you look at your own picture when you're
five years of age it's like this slowly
it's becoming like this
what is it you're dying in installments
the more conclusions you make the less
alive you become
this is all that's happened to people
they call this knowledge
this is not knowledge this is just
conclusions that you're drawing about
everything
see with all this scientific exploration
the fact is
that even today we do not know one
single atom in its entirety
we know how to use them we know how to
use everything on this planet
but we don't know a damn thing about
anything over 90 percent
or 99 of an atom is empty we don't know
what that emptiness
contains over 99 of the cosmos is empty
we don't know what that is so
this is like i give you a million piece
jigsaw but you found
in your hands you have only three of
them with these three you make a picture
and you're euphoric that you made a
picture well i'm sorry
there are million pieces to this
has anybody gathered all the pieces no
then don't make a picture there is
thought and there is emotion
people think these two things are saying
different things they are not saying
different things
the way you think is the way you emote
isn't it so
right now if i think oh she's the most
wonderful person on the planet
i just have to think then my emotions
become sweet
towards her now i think she is the most
horrible creature on the planet
now my emotions become nasty yes or no
i cannot think she's horrible and have
sweet emotions
i cannot think she's wonderful and have
nasty emotions
isn't it so but today i thought she's
the most wonderful person
and my sweetness was flowing suddenly
she did something tomorrow that i don't
like
i think she's horrible thought is agile
it changes direction just like that
emotion is little sappy
it takes time to turn around so that
period
you struggle as if there are two
dimensions of
thing happening because thought is
saying one thing emotion is still
going sweet because it takes time to
become nasty
everybody struggles but it catches up or
not after some time
hello today you thought she's wonderful
sweetness was flowing tomorrow she did
something you don't like
you thought she's horrible mind thought
is clearly saying she's horrible
but emotions are struggling because they
can't turn quickly
they take time to turn but after a week
or ten days or
two months depending on how deeply
you're engaged
after some time emotion catches up with
the thought
emotion also says yes she's not horrible
so will it be nasty to her
so they're not speaking different
languages
one is agile another is little slow in
his corners
if you focus whatever you're doing right
now it doesn't matter what it is
how simple an act you're doing right now
it doesn't matter
if you're absolutely devoted to that
that you're doing right now
depending upon various aspects things
will unfold
but because of western influences
we become too goal oriented
goal oriented means we are interested in
the
consequence but we are not interested in
the process
if you are not interested in the process
you should not be an artist
yes process is an end in itself
if you are absolutely devoted to the
process
depending upon various aspects something
will come out
but now we are interested in the
consequence
not in the process this goal
orientedness i want to get there i want
to get there
where the hell do you want to get
no i want to win the race see if you
treat life as a race
if you have to win it you have to get to
the finish line soon
isn't it you want to
hello if you get to the finish line
ahead of all these people you won the
race
you know what the finish line is we'll
be negotiating where to bury you
i can show you thousands of people
around me today
when they came they thought they won't
do anything significant half of them
not half 70 percent of them are dropouts
from schools and colleges and everything
but you will see after a few years of
sadhana
suddenly they are functioning in ways
that you won't believe possible
recently we had a business you know
event called insight
where over 200 ceos from across the
world are coming and participating
all of them wonder why our organizations
don't run
as smoothly and efficiently as yours
i said that's because i all have all
dropouts who are no good for anything
but they have devotion in their heart
they they're devoted to what they're
doing
that's all because they're absolutely
devoted to what they are doing
they may not be mbas they may not be
from iits and ims they're simple people
but because they're absolutely devoted
they do wonderful things
only when you're in a pleasant state of
experience your body and your brain
works at its best there's no argument
about that there's enough evidence to
show that
so whatever impact or success or
reaching goals or
growth or whatever you say on one level
in the physical world
it's about how well you harness your
physiological and your psychological
process
isn't it whether your body and mind
works against you
or works for you this is a big
difference
so there is enough evidence to show only
when you're in pleasant levels of
experience this happens
best so obviously joy is fast
then growth if you're joyful constantly
and you have no fear of suffering
because you understand
all human experience comes from within
you and so you have managed to create
the kind of experience that you want
now growth is possible and brittle if
you have the fear of falling down and
suffering
you will not go very high what a vision
and vision means
is everybody has desires
desire is an incremental way of
enhancing our life
today you desire i must have a home
tomorrow you desire i must have this
money tomorrow you desire something else
these are incremental ways of arranging
and rearranging our lives which are
needed to do a few things
when you say i'm a visionary what you're
saying is
i have a larger desire which is not
about just
incremental improvement of my life
desire is about me always
vision is an all-in all-inclusive
process
[Music]
so this itself is a phenomenal thing
if people instead of having desires if
they have a vision
vision is always all-inclusive
desire is personal
desire leads to incremental changes and
improvements
vision can transform the whole situation
so it's very important
that there is nothing to miss out in
life life is happening to all of us
question is only if i miss this party i
am missing out something
if i miss this examination i am missing
out something if i miss this job am i
missing out something this is simply
because
right now who you are is not internally
managed
it is externally stimulated when you
step out into the world
if you leave it to the people to decide
what happens within you
they're going to drive you crazy in no
time
here it's all managed for you you're not
managing this
it's managed for you what should happen
to you what should not happen to you
somebody else is managing it
when you step out on the street if you
leave it to other people's hands that
they can decide whether you're happy or
unhappy
you're going to be miserable for sure
because they want to do many things
what happens within you must be
determined by you
no technology is harmful
it is just that
when human mind
is in a certain level of destructive
mode
every technology is harmful
everything
you can take your laptop and slit
somebody's head
does it mean to say computers are
dangerous
suppose a few incidents happen like this
in many offices it happened let's say in
10 different offices
it so happened somebody took apple air
and slipped somebody's head
does it mean to say laptops are
dangerous
no human beings are stupid
whatever comes their way they know how
to turn it against themselves
when they've turned their own brains
against themselves
what else do you want
now there are technology d
addiction centers you know this
like there are drug deal addiction
alcohol due addiction
now technology addiction sentence
simply because we are in a compulsive
mode
[Music]
if we start eating we don't know when to
stop eating
that's a problem big problem quite a big
problem
if we start drinking we don't know when
to start drinking stop drinking
if we start shopping we don't know when
to stop shopping
if we start using the phone we don't
know when to stop using the phone
so the problem is not of technology the
problem is of compulsiveness
when we say compulsiveness it's just
absence of consciousness
isn't it if we were conscious human
beings
we would use everything for our
well-being and everybody's well-being
because we're compulsive we start doing
something we don't know how to stop
endlessly we will do the same silly
thing
so whether it's virtual reality or
artificial intelligence
or anything or anything the problem is
not
of technology never because they are
just devices
created by us we are supposed to use it
for our well-being
that's idea isn't it but see most of the
cutting edge technology
always goes into military usage in the
world
obviously we don't know how to use it
for a well-being we are always using it
to destroy something
this has been the thing always not just
now
because we've never worked on human
consciousness
if human beings lived consciously if the
leadership in the world was a conscious
leadership
a question of using technology against
human well-being or the well-being of
anything
wouldn't arise isn't it is
technology means enhancement of our
capability
fear is always about what may happen or
may not happen
right fear is not about what is
what we are experiencing right now what
will happen
is always the fear or in other words
your fear is about something which is
not yet
your fear is about something which does
not exist
this is all management people if there
were a few
somebody from a psychiatric department
you could have asked them
if i have fear about something that does
not exist
what is my condition they would have a
title for you
yes nimhans is close by i think we can
always consult that is also a premier
institution
we are suffering something which doesn't
even exist
yes if you are suffering something that
doesn't even exist
it is not about life it is not about
education it's not about career
it is just about your mind being out of
control
is that not an important aspect that you
should manage first before
we allow you to manage an industry or a
business is it not important first of
all you learn to at least
manage your mind hello
isn't it important if you do not know
how to manage your mind
what the hell are you going to manage in
the world
managers are all freaking out and
growing ulcers
in their stomachs yes today's become
normal
if you are a ceo by 45 if you don't have
an ulcer you're not a great ceo
because you are managing
by accident like this the fear comes
because there is an accidental
possibility isn't it
tell me let's say you don't know how to
ride a bicycle
you sat on it it was on stand you were
just pedaling for fun
and it came off stand and started
rolling anxiety or not
started rolling faster fear or no
very fast terror or no
[Music]
it's not because bicycle produces terror
it is just that you don't know how to
ride
if you know how to ride faster it goes
the better it is
isn't it faster it goes the better it is
the very
very uh basis why we created a bicycle
is because we wanted to go faster than
walking
that's the idea but if you do not know
how to ride
how much fear it creates right now your
problem is not with the world your
problem is not with your education
your problem is your education system
right from kindergarten hasn't told you
a damn thing
about how to manage yourself people are
having disturbed sleep because of the
way they're keeping their minds
if you are in a comfortable state of
mind
if you go to sleep the body knows when
to wake up one day it may sleep for this
many hours
another day it may sleep for half the
amount of time
it's perfectly fine body needs rest body
does not need
sleep restfulness is not in the hours
it is in the drop of metabolic activity
that you have
generally in deep sleep your metabolism
drops approximately eight percent
you sit for somebody your metabolic
activity can drop
up to 24 the restfulness that you're
gaining in meditation is
three times more profound than sleep
then one thing that will happen to you
is sleep quota will come down suddenly
see everybody is looking for tidbits of
life
give me three points with which i will
make my life
one mantra with which everything will be
solved
that's not how life is it's a
comprehensive process
the simple way to look at it is like
this
today you know because of medical
sciences
that your entire body in a way is a
chemical soup
the question is only is it a great super
lousy soup
[Laughter]
so if it's a great soup then it tastes
wonderful for you
and tastes wonderful for everybody
around you
if it's a lousy soup then
you have to manage with presentation
[Laughter]
when the chef is bad you know he
decorates it
right these days food comes with flowers
on it
never ever outside situations will
happen hundred percent your way
but what happens within you if it's
happening hundred percent your way
you will be in the best possible state
always you will keep yourself
in the best possible way are you as good
as somebody
that's not the point are you
full-fledged
that is the point effort has to be
incisive in the sense it should be
focused
calibrated simply if you make effort
it's foolish effort isn't it
just labor is not going to get you
somewhere
right kind of action the right timing
right
place all this is important isn't it
so for all these things to happen
you need perception and intelligence
so that's all you must do in your life
constantly looking for ways to enhance
your perception
and your intelligence rest will anyway
happen
this is one thing that unfortunately
humanity is not doing
they're trying to become capable of
something
do not try to become capable of
something
just enhance your perception and
intelligence see
if you're postponing something
you're obviously doing something that
you don't want to do
if there is something that you really
want to do will you postpone it or prep
on it
hello
do you see somebody is waiting for
someone they badly want to see
only 10 minutes in the 10 minutes they
will look at the watch 25 times
why they want to pre-op on it you're
doing something that you don't want to
do so you want to postpone it
i'm asking why the hell are you doing
something that you don't want to do
no because if i do this i will get that
i will get that
that's not the point there there's
nothing to get in this life
there's really nothing to get in this
life either you lived this life
in a profound and intense manner or you
did not
what will you get in the end
if somebody dies in the agricultural
college do they bury them or
fire them how is it what's a tradition
burying is good for agriculture because
human beings make good manure
so in the end what will happen to you
and me
they will either bury us or burn us
that's all will happen in the end
you think something else they'll give
you a prize
nothing will happen in the end only
thing is the process of life
how wonderfully did you live that's all
there is
so if you are doing something really
wonderful
do you want to preponate or postpone it
prepon only so you must find what is it
that you really want to do
if you find that one thing you will
always prep on everything every everyday
every moment if you remind yourself
this is a brief life and motto one day i
will end
just do this for two days and see you
will become
something truly fantastic within
yourself just this is all
and is simply beautiful that's all
that's needed
if you want to know the value of life
just know that it's a brief happening
just loosen up your life a little bit
laugh a little more involve yourself
with people around you
do things that you think is not so
important
don't do things which are very important
do simple things
it's very important you do simple things
very important things you're doing in
your life
you will become dead serious
you know burton russell an englishman
burton russell said if you're beginning
to think
that what you're doing is very important
you need to take a holiday
so holiday does not mean coming to india
holidays every day in those 24 hours you
must take a holiday
from your seriousness from yourself
seriousness has come essentially because
of your self-importance
you hold yourself as an important person
i want you to see you are like a speck
of dust in this existence
tomorrow morning if you disappear for
sure in india nobody will miss you
even down under they won't bother much
you know
a handful of people they will also
forget soon enough
isn't it
nature does you're gone
and nothing will happen in this world
everything will happen wonderfully well
even if you're not there
every human being should be aware of
this every moment of his life
it does not matter what the whole world
says about you
it does not matter how significant the
work you're doing
you must understand that tomorrow
morning the world will go on
fine without you
whoever you may be isn't it so
if you constantly remind yourself of
this you'll have no reason to be serious
[Music]
definitely not dead
and don't be dead now a time will come
it's time to be alive so much
unpleasantness
is happening in human experience because
we never took
charge of the inner dimension we believe
by fixing the outside everything is
going to be okay
in the last 100 150 years with the
advent of science and modern technology
we have fixed too many things on the
outside
if you fix any more there won't be a
planet left
yes definitely this has brought much
convenience and comfort to our lives
in every way we are the most
comfortable generation ever
you agree with me i know you have series
of complaints about how things are not
okay
but we are the most comfortable
generation ever before on this planet
isn't it so
but we cannot say we are the most joyful
generation on the planet we are the most
loving generation on the planet we are
the most blissed out generation the
planet definitely not
we are complaining complaining like
crazy about everything like never before
this is because we fixed the outside
comfort and convenience has happened
well-being has not happened
if your interiority
was handled by you consciously you would
definitely keep this in a blissful state
so he's bliss the goal of life no
bliss is a necessary condition for life
to flower
to its full potential otherwise it will
remain constrained
you're paying too much attention to
everything around you not enough
attention to this one
but the quality of your life is
essentially determined by
how you carry this one
this moment what kind of clothes you're
wearing
what kind of car you parked outside what
kind of home you live in
does not determine the quality of your
life this moment
how joyful are you feeling within
yourself determines the quality of your
life isn't it so
nothing has been done about it you think
it will happen in consequence
and you're setting impossible goals for
your happiness
if i have to be happy my wife should be
like this my
husband should be like that my children
should be like this the world should
become some other way
well these are impossible conditions
you're setting for your happiness and
peacefulness
now that you have compromised yourself
to peace
why i'm saying compromise yourself to
pieces
because a lot of people have given up
aspirations for being ecstatic
or blissful if i'm just peaceful it's
enough
even the so-called spiritual leaders are
going about and saying peace is the
highest goal
in your life peace is not the highest
goal in your life
if you want to enjoy your lunch today
you must be peaceful
yes or no if you're not even peaceful
there is nothing in your life that you
can do in a worthwhile way
to be peaceful essentially means this
that you're not messing your mind to be
peaceful
means that your system is at ease
you know how to conduct your mind you
know how to conduct your emotions your
body and your energies
you are peaceful it is not a rocket
technology
it is the most basic thing you have a
dog at home
you give him his food he sits peacefully
maybe not ecstatic
but peacefully many times they're
ecstatic also
yes your dog is able to sit pizza oh he
doesn't have to run my industry
that's not the point he's got his own
stuff going
see it has nothing to do with the
external activity that you're doing
it's got something to do with the
internal systems as to how they're
functioning
essentially it means either neither your
body nor your mind or your chemistry
know your emotions not your energy
are taking instructions from you they're
doing their own thing
once your machine is not in your control
being
peaceful is impossible i'll tell you you
get into your car
and now you go there and you want to
turn this way you do this to the
steering it goes this way
can you peacefully drive this car
can you no anxiety is natural
isn't it this is what has happened to
your vehicle
it's out of control you never done
anything to find out
where the steering wheel is first of all
this is not that simple as a car this is
a super super computer
now the problem is most people have not
even bothered to find the keyboard
they think if they do this somehow it'll
work
if you make when you're given such a
highly sophisticated machine
if you do not conduct it properly it
will cause many problems to you
by accident it's working i want you to
know this this is made this way
if you hold your hands like this it'll
breathe one way
if you just turn it around the very way
you breathe the breathing pattern itself
changes in your lungs
you can try it if you want when you have
the time this way
this way i'm saying everything that you
do
fundamental changes are happening in
this machine because it's such a
sophisticated machine
it's more than a touch screen if you
just wish it it will happen
when you have such a sensitive and
sophisticated machine
and you are operating like a blacksmith
then being peaceful seems to be
difficult
peace is not the highest goal in your
life it is the most fundamental
requirement don't
ever set peace as the highest goal if
you do that you will only rest in peace
you must see to be peaceful is the first
thing in your life
isn't it if you want to do anything
sensibly in your life
if you want to do conduct any situation
in your life sensibly
to be peaceful and happy is fundamental
you can
live life with ease not with struggle
[Music]
one thing is when we say work
it's a many young people wonderful
people who
are getting recognized for whatever
wonderful things they have done
living them apart but generally work
means
always been people have been taught that
they must work hard
nobody told them they must work joyfully
nobody told them their work should be an
expression of their joy or their love
they have to work hard you work hard
life will be tedious however how else
will it be
you will do something hard only because
you don't know how to do it
if you know how to do it you would do it
with ease so without learning how to do
something if you try to do it
without investing enough time and
perception
if life is all expression then life
becomes a big struggle
when the result of an event has no
impact on you
both ways you're blissed out you're a
success
when the fruit of when the fruit of the
action
does not determine how you are
it's just that you do things because
of the exuberance of what you do then
you are a success
the result may depend on variety of
things
results are not always yours results
for any result to happen whether it's in
a game or in life situations
there are various factors involved not
all of it is in our control
but what is in our control is either we
did our best
or we did not do our best that's in our
control
as long as we're doing that and
whatever the result may be if you are
still blissed out
that means you are a success because
life cannot defeat you anymore
how to conquer fear and apathy
on the way to success
that's all okay
fear about whether i will be successful
or not
where is apathy coming
no your individual fear about whether
i'll be successful or not is that what
you're talking
see that's that's exactly what i've been
telling you till now do not even think
of success
just enhance your capabilities strive to
enhance who you
are and what you can do you will anyway
do
isn't it right now
you have an idea of success but you
don't have
the competence for that you want to go
somewhere but you don't have the legs to
get there
now naturally there will be fear
naturally there will be all kinds of
unnecessary struggles and emotions
instead that at this stage in your life
if you just focus on seeing
how to enhance this human being to the
highest possible level that you can
success will be a downhill run not an
uphill task
so if you are going downhill there is no
fear isn't it
because whether i can get there or not
whether i can get there or not
you are working towards somebody else's
idea of success
you are working towards somebody else's
idea of success
that is not success your success is
you as a human being you found your full
potential this is your success
and that's all you can do whether you
stand on your head or you stand on your
feet
the best that you can do if this human
being finds his fullest potential
that's all you can do no matter what you
do you cannot do more isn't it
certain circumstances sometimes will
loft us up
certain circumstances sometimes may not
but in the given circumstance
if you have blossomed to your fullest
level you will do well isn't it
don't think of success and be fearful
about it just see how to make this one
more and more capable
if the competence and capability is
there success will come as we deserve it
all human experiences generated from
within is that
all human experiences generated from
within
so at any time if you feel happy or
unhappy miserable joyful ecstatic
in a state of agony doesn't matter what
happens
what is your experience pleasantness or
unpleasantness
just to know that it's happening from
within
and it can only happen from within
you can either take external stimuli
or you can create your own stimuli but
essentially
it happens from within
this one thing if it is not grasped
when you feel miserable if you think
it's this one
you're gone you're you just
the keyboard is here but you're punching
the wall
it's not going to work this one basic
fundamental thing
is something that almost 90 percent of
the humanity is always doing it wrong
whenever they feel miserable if they
think it must be this one or that one or
that one or
that one now
all human experiences generated from
within
if something is feeling unpleasant
first thing is to look at this what am i
doing wrong with this
am i eating wrong am i sleeping wrong am
i sitting wrong am i breathing wrong is
my heart beating wrong
something my very chemistry is wrong
something is wrong with this not with
that
so the moment you think by kicking the
wall you can fix this one
then you made a fundamental mistake the
harder you try
the further away from it you go the
first thing is to bring balance
once there is balance then you can build
a tower on top of this
if there is no balance whatever you
build will only lead to more trouble
the more basic you are the better it is
so this is what a whole lot of humanity
is seeking
somehow to remain basic because if you
build something
it feels terrible when there is no
fundamental balance
[Music]
anything standing up without balance is
a big
problem it is somebody's idea
of what is success isn't it don't become
a slave to somebody's idea
at least have your own idea
you have no idea of your own don't
deceive yourself
every idea every thought every emotion
every value that you have
is picked up from somewhere and it rules
you from within
it rules you from within your religion
your society your culture has trained
you to believe
that this is it
so first the first and foremost success
is
that you are not a slave to anybody's
idea
this is success if you come to the idea
of mortality
once in a way it will make you depressed
it will make you fearful if you live
with it every moment
it will make you absolutely exuberant in
the life
because it is
just this one thing
[Applause]
that this is not forever this is just
for a brief period of time
and the more joyful you are briefer it
becomes
if you're ecstatic it'll just vanish in
no time
yes so if you want to stretch it you
need to make yourself truly miserable
otherwise it'll be just gone in no time
if you come to terms with this if you
live
this way that every moment you
appreciate
one thing and only one thing because the
most important thing in your life is
you're alive right now
to be alive fully alive 100 alive
is the most important thing because only
if something is hundred percent alive
can you make it ill something beautiful
this happened
in the year 98-99
andrea garcia and boris becker played
three games
all boris becker beat andrea garcia
because he had
such a you know he was called boom boom
because
boris becker was called boom boom
because of the service his serves were
so powerful
there was no game every time he will
serve serve and finish the game
nobody returns the ball so andre agassi
went
back and studied hundreds of hours of
boris becker's
serves then he figured it out
then in the next three years he played
11 games with him
and beat him on 10 of them and
i'll tell you what happened after boris
becker retired
they met in germany there's something
called the october fest in germany they
were there
and at that time they were together and
andre agassi thought okay anyway he's
retired now i can tell him
because this bothered boris speaker big
time nobody can beat him but this guy's
getting at him so he told him see
i observed your videos continuously and
i figured out
that whenever you are serving the ball
towards the boundary line
boris becker if you know when he's
serving his tongue sticks out
a little bit when he throws the ball up
and
comes down his tongue sticks out said
whenever you're serving towards the
boundary line your tongue goes to the
left when you're serving straight
it comes out straight i observed this
the moment your tongue sticks out to the
boundary line i was already there every
time taking the ball
so boris becker literally fell off his
chair he couldn't believe this
and he said any number of times
i went home after the matches and i told
my wife
he seems to be reading my mind
but you've been reading my tongue
it's almost spoken so
your opponent should be never unfamiliar
to you
you must make him familiar you must know
him better than he knows himself
a human being does not become who he is
because of his desire he becomes who he
is because of his competence
so instead of enhancing your competence
you're just enhancing your desire
which will be just a horrible burden to
carry all the time
you just focus on enhancing the
competence of who this
is rather than enhancing your desire i'm
going to become a world champion
everybody wants to become one they're
not going to become one isn't it
everybody wants to be successful they
will not be a success unless you do the
right things
success will not happen to you can i
tell you a joke
45 minutes you've got to be serious
we can go yes
we need the joke yes okay let me ask you
this question
let me tell you
even better
on a certain day a man fell into a
septic tank
right up till here in felt
he desperately tried to come out he
could not
then he started screaming fire fire
neighbors heard this call the fire
brigade fire
firemen came rushing they looked all
over the place no fire
then they found this man they pulled him
out and then they asked why were you
screaming fire where is the fire
the man retorted if i said would you
come
you got to do the right things otherwise
the right things will not happen to you
just because you have a big desire
you're not going to get there you got to
do the right things
various situations in your life
either you can use it
to make yourself stronger and better
or you can sit and cry this is the
choice you have
everything it doesn't matter what
happens
the most horrific event happened in your
life
that also can be used for your growth
and your well-being
if only if you have clearly seen the
small
events of your life when i say small
events
i mean your business your marriage your
children
all those big things
all these things are just a stepping
stone so
the fear of failure
failure is bad enough fear is adding
spice to it
isn't it
success happens to you not because you
desire it
because you earn it
everybody desires it it comes only if
you're capable of
it see the reason the only reason a
human being
will seek to know something is because
he realizes that he does not know
if he does not realize that he does not
know
there will be no longing to know there
will be no seeking to know
and definitely there will be no knowing
it's not possible whether it is
spiritual seeking
or any other kind of knowledge you will
seek only because you realize you do not
know
if you think you know everything or you
believe you know everything
you will be just too full of yourself
that's all
and that is a huge problem that's a very
big problem
though we have a culturally cultivated
humility
that you see all over the place
everybody is like this only but still
too full of yourself when you bend
nothing goes out of your head
it doesn't make any space i'm saying
because my head is open that's why i'm
bandaged can you see
if you try to control the variety of
situations that may pop up in your face
tomorrow morning
all that will happen is you will become
a very limited life
you would step out into the world and do
whatever that needs to be done
only if you have an assurance no matter
what you walk into you will not lose
yourself
you will walk full stride otherwise
you'll only be a half a step
most human beings are half steps because
the fear of suffering
if this happens what will happen to me
if that happens what will happen to me
if you're well managed within yourself
you know how to manage your thought you
know how to manage your
emotion you know how to manage your body
your chemistry your energy if you know
how to manage all this
what does it matter if you walk into
hell i'm asking
if you are well managed if you are a
heaven within you
what does it matter where you go hell
also will be an interesting place to go
but if you are ill-managed then you want
to be in a nice place
all the time you will not step out into
anything
i am not saying this is wrong this is
against nature
because in nature every life is aspiring
to be as much as it can be isn't it
every life is naturally aspiring this is
not a philosophy
this is not an ideology that you must do
this or that
it is natural and intrinsic for every
life
that you will do as much as it can
from an earthworm from a worm to an
insect to a bird
to an animal to a tree every one of them
are trying to be full-fledged life
if you go against this simply because of
the fear of suffering
then all possibilities of exploring the
nature of being human
the tremendous immensity of being human
is just lost upon humanity today you
will see this everywhere
when people say i am only human
they are talking about the limitations
of being human
they are not talking about the
possibilities of being human
isn't it when if we
are the most intelligent species on the
planet
if we are the most capable species on
the planet
should we be talking about our
possibilities or should we be talking
about
our limitations whenever anybody
writes or says oh we are human
they're always referring to their
limitations never to the possibilities
of being human
this is because the the most fundamental
things have not been taught in our
education systems
how to handle your thought and your
emotion
your psychological drama has gone out of
control
a badly directed drama believe me
if it was a well-directed drama you
would take it to the conclusion that you
want
isn't it because it's a badly directed
drama
just about anybody can take charge of it
who is the director of your
psychological drama just about anybody
isn't it
anybody can make it into a tragedy
competition is a good thing
if you're incompetent and you're in
competition you will feel stressed
so if you want to be in a competitive
situation
the thing is you have to work on your
competence
right now the problem is you're tweaking
your desire
you're not tweaking your competence this
is what has to happen
that we must teach children to tweak
their competence
not their desire we are calling this
ambition
we are calling this goal-orientedness
ambition means what you tweaked up your
desire
you will suffer invariably if you tweak
up your competence
you will see wherever you go you are
doing better than what people expect you
to
so naturally things will go well for you
competition is not the bad thing lack of
competence is the bad thing
so instead of competence
we have big desires
if you focus enough on enhancing your
competence
you will see there is such joy in
breaking limitations every day and
becoming something better
you don't care a damn how somebody else
is doing let's say you have to cook
something let's say you have to bake a
cake or you want to
cook some rice you turn on the stove
turn off this towel turn on this towel
turn off this towel
it's a long process
and of course dinner won't happen
so this is the story of
the majority of the spiritual seekers
they're off and on and off and on and
off and on
oh does it mean to say i must be only
here there that's not it
the priority should not shift the
priority is set
slowly everything within you will slowly
organize itself in that direction
because the priority is shifting this
life does not know which way to go
it's just confused every two minutes if
you change the destination on the gps
for sure it does not know where to go
isn't it
so this is what is happening for in most
people this is why
spiritual path seems to be orders long
impossible
unattainable all these things simply
because people are shifting priorities
all the time
is it true that every other creature on
this planet
a worm an insect a bird an animal
with a millionth of our brain they're
conducting their life
process quite well hello
are they when i say life process
we are born they're born just like that
we grow up they grow up we make a living
they make a living
we may reproduce they reproduce we do
all this with enormous fuss
they'll simply do it yes or no
every simple thing we're doing with
enormous fuss
they're simply doing it different
various processes of life and death they
are doing it
without fuss we are doing everything
with great fuss
is this a sign of highest level of
intelligence i'm asking
we are supposed to be the most
intelligent and there is no question
that we have the most evolved
neurological process
on the planet yes
we have the most evolved neurological
system that we must be able to sense and
feel and experience
and perceive understand and express
things in the highest possible way but
no other creature on the planet is
struggling like the human creature
right now this is simply because
you have been given a super super
computer do you agree with me
that this is the most sophisticated
gadget on the planet
not the iphone the eye
but now the question is have you read
the user's manual
that's all people have not read the
user's manual for the most complex
machine on the planet
and somehow blundering through somehow
trying to use it
everything is a problem tell me one
thing that human beings are not
suffering
if they're poor they suffer their
poverty you make them rich they suffer
the taxes
if they're not educated they suffer that
put them to school
a lot of suffering
not married they suffer that get them
married
i didn't say anything i didn't say a
thing okay
no children some people suffer that
children daily suffering
so you seem to be suffering every aspect
of life
so if you offer death will you go
joyfully no you will suffer that
so tell me one thing that we are not
suffering now people view philosophies
life is suffering
no no life is not suffering nor is it a
joy
it's simply there it's a phenomena if
you ride it
it feels fantastic if you're crushed by
it it feels terrible
so are you riding the wave of life
or are you being crushed by it that's
all the question is
as a generation if you create a huge
amount of positives
negative will become small
if you create huge amount of negatives
they will become big and positive will
become small
this whole life is there has never been
a point
any time and there never will be where
everything is perfect
okay there's no such thing
because life is a possibility because
it's a possibility it cannot be perfect
it doesn't matter what we do there's
still something more to do
always that is why it's an endless
possibility
striving does not mean i want to be a
good man i want to be a good man
see being morally good
is only good for the society not good
for the human being
yes if if you're morally correct
it's good for people around you because
you're contained
but it's not good for this life
so this life needs a little different
kind of nurture
in that context how many people in this
world
are going to strive before you and me
fall dead
how many people in how many people will
be set the seed
that they will be striving to be a
better life than the way they are right
now
a little higher expression of life
this is all your focus should be people
start developing these things
for everything when their logic fails
they will think that you know
you want to do something you don't know
how to do it
you're not sure whether to do it or not
do it then the simple solution they're
taking is okay this finger is this this
finger is this yes no
give it to the child if he holds this
yes if he holds this no
this is not intuition no i will come to
you
i'm not i'm going more basic
the answer is not just about you i'm
just using it
now this is just that your logic has
become
you know incapable it's collapsed unable
to come to your logical decision
so you are succumbing to this simple way
if some child holds your hand like this
or like this yes or no
anyway when there are two options 50 of
the time you could be right
yes being 50 of the time right is not
good enough
isn't it yes isn't it so
i was you know
some time ago i was visiting a a
homeopathic doctor
there in his clinic they put up an ad
some homeopathic medicine which will
work for all kinds of snake bites
living in bombay pro probably it's not
an issue for you
where i come from snakes are everywhere
on a daily basis
so i looked at this and then i asked him
how come
this medicine you're advertising that it
works for all kinds of snake bites
because
if you are not already aware of this
snake bias are fundamentally of two
kinds
one type of venom attacks your
cardiovascular system another kind of
venom
attacks your nervous system the two
completely different kind of chemicals
and it works upon your system in a
different way
generally for both you have different
types of antidotes
but for everything this particular
medicine is supposed to work how is that
possible
so the doctor said see in india
90 percent of the indian snakes are
non-poisonous
so 90 percent of the time it works
so that's not good enough isn't it
it's the remaining 10 which is crucial
isn't it
so intuition don't get into this thing
about you
trying to be intuitive never try to be
intuitive
logic is dependable isn't it
there are moments when there is certain
clarity
which has no logical explanation at that
time it's okay but you never
try to be intuitive if you try to be
intuitive
your logical mind will become deceptive
and come to all kinds of stupid
decisions you will get suddenly guidance
voices from the heaven
you know all kinds of voices people are
hearing
logic is dependable go by it at least
you won't make a fool of yourself
if you can find a place where there are
no
sounds of machines and
your cell phone will not think think
quietly if you can listen to the sound
of the trace the breeze the water
just the natural sounds if you pay
enough attention
tremendous things will happen to you
[Music]
many times i've been in
the south indian you know their kind of
tropical rainforest
the longest i've been there through the
jungle for about 23 days alone
no any kind of support no cell phone for
sure those days
and not even a torchlight and fourth day
i ran out of the food that i was
carrying
so i lived off the forest
by about eight a day i lost my jacket
and one half of my shirt because i was
chased by some animals and by
that whole thing i had half a shirt
and pants
[Music]
and i walked through ice
this is elephant country tiger country
i saw tigers panthers elephants all
kinds of
the wild buffalo various kinds of
animals very close quarters
but at the end of it when you look back
what is the biggest impact on you it's
the insects
it's in the nights the orchestra
that goes on in the rainforest oh my
god it's unbelievable
and the timing every day
night 2 15
means one group will stop and the other
group will start
really their sense of time every day
exactly by the second one group will
start
another group will start and
you don't know what they're talking
about
they're definitely talking something
that you don't know for sure
they're not just making dumb noises
so if you just sit there and listen and
listen and listen and listen
slowly you start noticing there is a
pattern and an organization to this
which is far bigger than any human
symphonies that you can achieve
[Applause]
far more complex and
far more intense
[Music]
i think it's very important for every
human being
particularly if you have children
vacation need not be disneyland i'm not
against it but
one trip is enough all silly stuff which
excites you
vacation should be into nature
if you can take your children walk in a
jungle
not in a resort
just live on a mountain expose them to
nature i will tell you you will
bring up your children not only
physically healthy mentally healthy
far more sensible and accepting and
wonderful kind of human beings
if they know how to because once you go
into nature
whose son you are whose daughter you are
what are you in the city doesn't matter
okay it's very important that everybody
experiences that otherwise
you start creating your own illusions as
to who you are and you start believing
it for sure
it's time to understand
all the problems of individual nature
are generated from within
and we don't have to solve problems that
we create
we just have to dissolve
no problems that you create you don't
have to solve
if there is a problem in the situation
yes we have to solve
but you have a problem within you
solution is not what you need
solution is madness solution means
for an illusion you're creating an
illusory solution
something that you make up for that you
create one more solution that you made
up once again
now you just have to turn off the
problems
you're going through a certain drama
only thing is you're a lousy director
that's all there is means of improving
your direction
now you're trying to find a solution
for a situation in a drama
it's like people watch a cinema and come
home and they have big arguments about
what happened there
so the thoughts and emotions that you
create
you don't have to find any solution for
it
if you just turn it off it's gone
if you find solution you
moving towards insanity because
you create a ghost and you create a
ghostbuster
the ghost that you create you must learn
to play with them
hello
i'm saying if nobody willing to play
with you you have to play with somebody
right
so the ghosts you create if you like
them you play with them
if you don't like them turn them off
but guru they keep coming
[Applause]
you don't play
don't like to play with them don't play
they come and go
never it ever happened that one thought
remained for more than a moment isn't it
it comes and goes comes and goes let it
come and go
if you try to find a solution for that
you will head towards insanity
you told the story of a man who had
wings
but never used them to fly and just
reproduce and had a life and
isn't it a tragedy that he'd never use
his wings to fly
do you feel like most of us are walking
through life with wings and we never use
them to fly
unfortunately yes a whole lot of people
too many people
it's time that human potential is
unleashed because we are the first
generation on the planet
for whom our survival is organized
better than ever before
ever so this is the time
to unlock our potential to lose those
all kinds of inhibitions and fears
that we had there was a time if as much
as
a cloud gathered and lightning and
thunder happened we thought
god was angry with us right okay
all those things are gone it is time you
take away the nonsense that's happening
within you
and the entire process the science of
inner engineering is just this
how to work at it in a scientific manner
not with philosophy i can tell you a
thousand times give up your fear it's
not going to go
but if your chemical soup is blissful
there's not even a idea of fear in your
mind
[Music]
it reminds me of your concept of the
movies you play the movies in your mind
you can choose a drama you can choose a
horror story or you can choose
a positive movie and not get stuck in
the same movie forever you can
turn it off and start a new one yeah but
for that you should know where the
switches are right you are uh
like a super computer but you haven't
found the keyboard yet
time to find the keyboard that's my work
to give people the keyboard to their
super computer
one thing that you must do to yourself
is
you are absolutely truthful to yourself
if you're also truthful to everybody
around you you will get other kinds of
benefits with people
but i will not go that far right now
with yourself you are 100 truthful
otherwise all kinds of tricks keep
happening
to be truthful to yourself is not a
easy thing because there is
lifetimes of habit of simply
bullshiting yourself a guest came to
shankaranpula's house
and being a south indian man down south
you know
pillai's come from further down south
he was carrying an umbrella which is
common thing
in kerala and southern tamil nadu to
carry an umbrella is a very common thing
because
rains can be very heavy
then they walked out he took the guest
out then it started raining
the shangri-la did not open the umbrella
the guest said why don't you open the
umbrella saying grandpa i said
i'm sorry the umbrella is full of holes
then the guest asked why did you bring
it well i never thought
it will rain today
a whole lot of people are like this
they think somebody else has to catch
their lies
this will take a long time because
someone else catching your lies will
take lifetimes
you must catch them you should not let
your chickens pass
to become hundred percent straight with
yourself
you take a certain amount of application
but
if this one thing you do as a thomas
this piece of life will work for sure
100
then figuring out a few things is very
simple
for that i am there if you just fix one
this
this one thing that you're 100 straight
no any kind of deception when there's a
hole in the umbrella you know there is a
hole in the umbrella
you will never forget that there is a
hole in the umbrella okay
if you are like this rest of the work
becomes very simple
and easy the purpose of business
or the purpose or the goals of big
business is to expand
you can expand in two different ways one
is by conquest
another is by embrace i can conquer you
or i can embrace you both ways you will
become mine
if i embrace you you will become mind
willingly
and i will have better use of you in
every possible way
i'm talking business not it's not my
personal thing
but if i conquer you i will still have
you
but i have to sit on top of your head
and make you do things
and you will do everything possible to
make my life miserable
yes or no true absolutely so people are
trying to conquer
and their businesses and their activity
is doing everything possible to make
them miserable and you can see it on
their faces
successful people are showing miserable
faces
which is a wrong message to send to the
world particularly to the youth
if you send a message that success is
misery
you're destroying humanity success is
the sweetest thing that can happen to a
human being
but now you take the most successful 10
000 people on the planet
you will see they are an epitome of
tension
and anxiety and misery
you are sending a completely wrong
message this you can see took such a bad
turn
in united states of america in the 60s
the so-called corporates brutally
wanting to grow conquer the world
set such an image of themselves the
youth thought it's better to sit in the
street corner and smoke pot
and it's a better way to live at least
you're happy you're not causing any
damage to anybody
this is a horrible way to exist so it's
extremely
important that successful people send a
clear message
success is a beautiful thing it is not a
suffering it is not a miserable thing to
do in your life
if this has to happen your expansion has
to happen by embrace
not by conquest spiritual process means
to become like a mountain
stable still
because
it's only when somebody has a very
stable base
many things can be done
exuberance of life is possible only if
there is
absolute stability otherwise
exuberance will lead to madness
yes that's why a lot of people
who are a little creative a little
active little
exuberant always end up being freaky and
nearly insane
because without stability you cannot
have a dance going
this is why
shiva means stillness shiva means dance
at the same time
either you see him sitting absolutely
still
or you see him in an explosion of dance
because an explosion is possible only
when there is a stable base
an explosion which is not destructive
is possible only when there is stability
and stability people try to become
stable by
controlling and trimming their lives
this is the way your grandmother would
tell you how to be stable
control yourself then you will be stable
yes if you're dead you will be stable
ready
i promise you that
so normally people who talk about
stability are all
[Music]
constipated existence you know what's
constipation
that means it happens little by little
[Music]
their joy their love their ecstasy
happens little by little here and there
that's constipation
so stability is not because you have
trimmed your life down
or pruned it down to minimal and you're
stable
that's of no consequence
stability because you see everything
utterly clearly
that is why when we say adi yogi
we're talking about stability at the
same time in exuberant dance
this is possible only because he has
more than two eyes
not necessarily three more than two
that means he sees much more than most
people ever see
because he sees much much more
able to be stable stability it takes
to allow exuberance to happen otherwise
you keep curtailing your exuberance
because it hurts
when it's out of balance if you're out
of balance and you move at a certain
speed you're going to hurt yourself
whether you're riding a bicycle or
you're riding the cosmos
if you're out of balance and you attain
speed you're going to hurt yourself very
badly
so balance is very important
and balance that comes out of
curtailment is not balanced that's
you know packaged death on a certain day
a bull and a pheasant were grazing
bull was chomping the grass pheasant was
picking off picking ticks off the bull
partnership
the huge tree at the edge of the field
the pheasant very nostalgically looked
at the tree and said oh alas there was a
time i could fly to the topmost branch
of the tree
now i do not have enough strength in my
wing even to get to the first branch
the bull very nonchalantly said that's
no issue
just eat a little bit of my dung every
day within a fortnight you'll get there
pheasant said come on what kind of
rubbish is that the bull said really try
and see the whole humanities on it
so very hesitantly the pheasant started
pecking at that down
and low on the very first day it reached
the first branch of the tree
within a fortnight it reached the
topmost branch of the tree
just beginning to enjoy the scenery an
old farmer was rocking on his rocking
chair saw a fat old pheasant sitting on
top of the tree
pulled out his shotgun and shot the bird
off the tree
the moral of the story is many times
even [ __ ] can get you to the top but
it never lets you stay there
this happened in 1941
this is just when the nazi movement was
building up in germany and
in some parts of europe so one day in
austria
a bunch of german soldiers came broke
into the homes
the jewish family a rich family they
broke the home
and took away the adults took everything
was robbed
and these two children a 12 year old
girl and an eight-year-old boy were
taken away
they were taken to a railway station
this is the month of
nowhen december kind of time when
it's becoming very cold so they were
kept on the railway station for three
days because the trains did not come
boys little boys being boys they started
playing football
so they were playing football and then
suddenly the train came
the train is not a passenger train it's
a cargo train
a good stream so when the train came the
soldiers came and rushed everybody into
the
the wagons which are there everybody got
in and the little boy and the girl
also got in but the little boy forgot to
wear his shoes
he left his shoes outside and they
pushed him into the wagon
so without shoes he came his
sister a 12 year old girl saw her kid
brother
coming without shoes and she got mad
with him
she held him by the year boxed his ears
scolded him nicely slapped him
say you eat it already we are in enough
trouble
now you come without shoes because in
germany in winter no shoes means you may
lose your feet
so she's angry about that in the next
station the boys and girls were
separated
after four years after the war was over
she came out of the concentration camp
to find
17 members of her family including
her little brother all had vanished
no records no sign of them they just
evaporated
at that time the only thing that
bothered her was
the last few things that she said to her
little brother
she loves her brother but the last few
things that she said to him
were such terrible things it rang in her
mind
and troubled her these are the last
things i told
my brother and after that i'm never
going to see him he's gone
so she took a vow if i speak to anybody
in my life
i will speak in such a way if this is my
last word
i will not regret
this one thing transformed her life in
such a way
she went on to united states she died in
2006
she did some phenomenal work built a
hospital
somewhere near chicago i think
she lived a fruitful life i'm saying
even if you put through the most
horrible situations
either you can come out using that
experience as a better human being
or you can use the experience to become
a horrible mess
so whenever something hurts you there
are two options
you can either become wounded or you can
become wise
this is the choice the more things hurt
you
early on in your life the wiser you
should have become
isn't it but unfortunately most people
become
wounded this is simply because
they just need an excuse to turn their
own intelligence against themselves
that's all especially if the world
around you
turns against you is it not very very
important
that your intelligence stands up for you
the fear of suffering
is not just about pain the fear of
suffering
is self-inflicted nobody can cause
mental pain to you it is you in reaction
to something that happens around you
that you cause pain to yourself if you
have half your brain removed
then you would see you would be quite
peaceful
right now people are going through
stress anxiety depression
misery all kinds of things
you can give it any number of exotic
names that you want but
essentially their intelligence is turned
against them that's all it is
once your intelligence is against you
there is no force on the planet
or anywhere which can save you so the
fundamental thing is
to bring this that all the faculties
that we have
should work for our well-being
right now our own body our own mind our
own emotions are working against us
this one thing has to be fixed just to
give a little bit of context we saw the
video sakuraji
running on himalayas playing football
playing cricket so
in that context how to keep yourself on
the go all the time
on the go you don't have to be on the go
all the time
if life demands people ask me so guru
how are you
active like this because generally my
schedule is anywhere between
18 to 20 hours a day seven days of the
week 365 days
non-stop for many years it's going on
i'm i'm complaining and the guy is
clapping about it
so people keep asking how do you keep
yourself like this how do you do this
see i'm essentially lazy
it's just that the situation in the
world
demands action left to myself
i would close my eyes and simply said
i'm made like this if i close my eyes
i can sit like this till i fall dead
really
i have really no need for action i'm not
trying to keep myself busy
there's a lot to be done so you're doing
people ask me sadhguru what's your dream
what is your dream i said my dream is
the day i am
unemployed that's a great day because if
i am unemployed it simply means
everybody is doing fantastic what more
do you want
dream fulfilled so action
is not something that you decide you
just
decide your intent action the world will
decide how much of what
i am you know at these economic forums
in sevilla i'm at the
world economic forum this guy
from the business schools in harvard
business school one professor comes
oh you're that amazing tree planter i
said no i'm not a tree planter
he said no no you planted those millions
of things yes i did but i'm not a tree
planter
then what do you do i said i make
people flower not plant trees but
i'm planting trees because the goddamn
trees are missing
where they should have been
where they should have been they are not
there it's like this
two men were working on the street one
man is digging pits
behind him another man is coming and
closing and closing and going
somebody else was driving by they saw
this ridiculous activity
one guy digs the pit another guy closes
the pit
so they stopped and said hey what are
you doing here why are you guys
working like this one guy digging
another way closing
they said no no the in-between guy
has gone and leave he's the tree planter
he's not there we're doing our work so a
lot of people are doing work like
i'm doing my work you have no work on
this planet
if the planet needs work if the world
needs work we will do it
otherwise why should i think this is my
work
so guru what's your mission so no
mission i'm just fooling around a bit
because you have no business
to have your own mission life has its
own mission
in some way if you can assist and serve
that that's about it
what is it that you have your own
mission are you some kind of a tyrant
all missionaries are tyrants in some way
unknowingly
yes those who think they have a mission
there is no mission
what is needed you do especially when
you
study in a business school and get
certain competence to manage things
or create things you must create what is
needed
not create some rubbish and push it on
them
yes yes or no you must see
how to make life better how to solve
situations
which are problematic to a whole lot of
people you must look for solutions and
solutions for the existing situations
and of course there are experts who go
on creating new problems
so you will never be short of problems
believe me
you just have to create solutions not go
on a mission mode
that's for mussolini just because
somebody is successful
this doesn't mean they've figured out
everything this doesn't mean they're at
ease with life
this doesn't mean their life is in some
way fulfilled
no because today our idea of success is
just doing little better than somebody
else
you doing little better than somebody
else means
and you're very happy about that what it
means is you're actually
enjoying other people's failures
if somebody enjoys another person's
failure or
i call that sickness not success what do
you call it hello
[Music]
i enjoy that you failed
this is sickness this is not success
isn't it
unfortunately this is how you're going
this is the reason why
human potential is not unleashed
because if you're racing with a lame
person
you're just happy you're one step ahead
of him only when you meet mr bolt
you understand who the hell you are
yes till then you think you are a great
runner because other person doesn't have
legs
so what's the secret behind your success
as a child
did you blow soap bubbles
soap bubbles
so when you blew soap bubbles have you
seen
somebody got this big bubble you got
only this big bubble
we must hold our breath and leave it
slow then we'd get a bit bubble
everything
everybody had air in the lungs but
somebody got a big bubble
somebody got a small bubble
what is this about see when it comes to
body this is my body that is your body
100 clear no
confusion about this isn't it this is my
body
that is your body this is my mind that
is your mind
but when it comes to life there is no
such thing as
my life and your life
this is a living cosmos how much life
will you capture
within your system will determine the
size and scope of your life
somebody got a big bubble somebody else
got a small bottle
poop it went off you cannot identify
where is my air and where is your air is
something
so similarly when it comes to life there
is no such thing as my life and your
life
but distinctly my body and your body my
mind and your mind
but know my life and your life there is
life
abundant life this is a living cosmos
how much life will you capture within
yourself
will determine the scope and range of
your life
what one person can do in 100 years
somebody may do it in 10 years
because of the sheer intensity of life
when i say intensity of life it may
translate in many different ways
see there are times for example
certain businesses have grown
let us say uh some business like uh you
know in the united states this become a
fed
within three years somebody's billions
of dollars of worth of business
let us say microsoft has grown or
facebook has grown or something like
this has grown
this is largely because of technological
breakthroughs and somebody
writes that technology
at another time that would not have
happened
so that is different but
if you want to create something really
large
really significant large or small is not
the point significance
then you need intensity of life
one thing is the scale of life that you
capture there are
this is what i said earlier when i said
yoga obliterating
in boundaries of your individuality
means
in a way you are allowing universe to
invade you
when universe is not against you but it
invades you or it's a part of you
then you have abundance of life
when you have abundance of life you will
not hesitate to share
when you share big time your life
with everybody else
people will naturally value it immensely
because everybody is trying to hold it
somebody is willing to share it so
naturally there will be a big upsurge
around you this will lead to many things
this will make many friends and many
enemies
a lot of people whom you have never met
they are your
own enemies but you don't know why
you never met them you never had a word
with them but they are swearing that i
am his enemy
i don't know why but it goes on in the
world
so when we talk about how so much can be
done in a short span of time
it's not a short span of time it's 37
years
incessant work seven days of the week
20 hours a day almost for 25
years more than 25 years
on an average i slept only for two and a
half hours a day
not deprived of sleep just kept my life
energy so intense
that sleep was not even an issue there
are times when i've gone without sleep
for three days four days
full scale working not because
you're on some kind of a drug and
not sleeping simply because of the
intensity of purpose and commitment to
what you're doing
today i can proudly say i have created
thousands of people around me
all of them have gotten crazy like that
they all beginning to work like this
most of them
you don't know when they will sleep when
they will wake up on
on on seven days of the week
no holidays no vacations but everybody
is joyful
if you come to the yoga center and see
you will see the most joyful faces
but they've never been on a vacation
they don't own a damn thing
they don't have money in their pockets
but they're just joyful
because drunk with life literally
now i've got a special bonus script from
subguru on how to read the user's manual
of
life that i think you're going to enjoy
but before that question today i want to
know
what clip spoke to you the most you've
watched all of these videos now
you've been inspired been motivated what
spoke to the most what change are you
gonna make in your life for your
business
as a result of watching this video let
me know put it down the comments below
and if you made it this far in the video
and you promise you commit to take
action believe nation we don't just
watch
videos we do something we act if that's
you
give me a hashtag but leave in the
comments as well so i can celebrate with
you
of all the pieces of engineering on this
planet
of many pieces of engineering a tree is
a fantastic engineering even a mountain
is fantastic engineering because it
stood there for a million years that
means it must be good engineering isn't
it
yes something that stands there for a
million years
must be well engineered
of all this the most sophisticated piece
of engineering is
human mechanism isn't it so
hello most sophisticated
of all the pieces of engineering
now because it's a sophisticated piece
of engineering
it needs a certain level of attention
otherwise you don't figure it
now that we gave you such a highly
you know high-tech piece of engineering
i'm asking you did you read the uses
menu
i i think there is no user manual for
now
how can they make such a fantastic piece
of engineering without a user's manual
maybe it doesn't come with a booklet
attached to your neck when you were born
but indications must be there isn't it
how to use it
is it true somebody who's an athlete or
a gymnast or someone else like that
learns to use their body than a whole
lot of other people
yes obviously at least one aspect
of the physical engineering of the body
they seem to have read the user's manual
about the physical aspects
is it true certain people are able to
use their mind better than others
maybe they read another part of the
user's manual
so now uh with
this heart manual and the brain manual
see the problem is most people are
prejudiced against the brain
this is a question or always comes to me
sadhguru i want to meditate but
thoughts are coming
the common question everywhere i ask
them see
i'll make you meditate we will stop the
liver we'll stop the kidney we'll stop
the heart we'll stop
everything okay
so you want the liver to function when
you're meditating
you wonder kidneys to function you want
even the spleen to function you want the
heart to function
but you don't want your brain to
function for some reason
this is simply because brain is a new
equipment that you got in the
evolutionary process
this level of cerebral development
happened more recently
compared to the other systems if you cut
open
any mammal they all have all these parts
isn't it
every part that you have here all of
them have
even if you open a frog most of you
your biology department
even if you open a frog almost
everything that you have
he also has isn't it it is only the big
difference is only the cerebral
development which is a more recent
happening
because it's a more recent happening
most people have not figured how to
handle it
so user's manual is very important you
don't read a user's manual
just before you discard the machine you
read it
in the first few days isn't it hello
if you buy a phone do you want to read
the user's manual
in the first three days or after three
years when you're throwing it away
first three days isn't it so
knowing how this functions is very
important never
did ever heart generate any thought
or intention
well when you looked at the young girl
heartbeat
more that doesn't mean it's saying
anything it's just trying to compensate
for the other levels of excitement
that's happening
if you want more life-changing advice
from monks and gurus check out the video
right there next to me i think you'll
enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there if you try to control
the variety of situations that may pop
up in your face tomorrow morning
all that will happen is you will become
a very limited life